hello and welcome to the first reality
check of 2015 a year which according to
Back to the Future Part 2 at least is
one will finally get hoverboards self
tying shoes and home energy reactors I'm
sure we've got top men working on that
while we wait for those perhaps the most
oh my god the future is now pieces of
tech that will soon be available to us
of virtual reality headsets while the
oculus rift and Sony's project Morpheus
take immersion in gaming to the next
level there is always a disconnect
between what you see and how you
experience it what I mean is you're
confined to interacting with the game
world through some kind of controller
doing this to kill an enemy it's just so
much more immersive than just simply
pushing a button also it feels weird
that your real-life hands don't match
with your hands that are in the game so
how can some of the coolest science to
come out of 2014 help to improve the
upcoming VR experience
let's get rid of those pesky controllers
first oculus recently acquired nimble VR
a company focused on making a peripheral
for the rift which aims to do just that
it's a small infrared depth sensing
camera like a mini Kinect without the
fluffy animals and it's perched on top
of your headset and tracks your hand
movements there is not being high
quality low latency tracking that
doesn't require those weird public suits
that you see in regular mocap which is
incredible it's like a more immersive
Kinect imagine Skyrim in the rift
casting spells fighting bandits fixing
puzzles proper interaction with the
environment well sort of
you're still grasping at thin air but
recent advances in haptic technology
could help take things to the next level
damn it James you might know haptics
better as touch feedback technology like
the rumble in your controller when you
get hit by an enemy or the chattering of
a joystick when your vehicle collides
with another researchers at the
University of Bristol have discovered
ways to use haptic technology and
ultrasound to create 3d shapes by
focusing complex patterns of ultrasound
onto our hands it causes air
disturbances which we can then see and
even feel head researcher dr. Ben Long
believes the tech could be used by
doctors to explore CT scans using the
haptic feedback to field diseases such
as tumors that's incredible enough by
itself but imagine if the technology was
used in conjunction with VR headsets
if you've read ready player one by
Ernest Cline and this is basically the
Oasis simulator in real life
one great potential market for VR
headsets is that of horror games games
like outlast amnesia and alien isolation
are already playable in the rift and
according to YouTube videos well it
looks like a pretty terrifying
experience I can't decide if it's the
actual jump scare itself that's the
worst or the build up the constant
lingering feel of dread because you
think something's there
interestingly researchers are now saying
that they've uncovered just what causes
that feeling of a presence phenomenon a
team led by Olaf Blanca in Switzerland
worked with a range of epilepsy migraine
and stroke patients and discovered that
they were perceiving presences due to
the damage in three particular areas of
their brains these areas are responsible
for integrating sensory
signals from both inside and outside the
body but due to damage they were
confused causing the phenomenon so
that's the why but the researchers also
figured out how to induce this
phenomenon in people without brain
damage by building a robot of course in
front of the volunteers was a master
robot arm and by moving it the
volunteers got a bit of touch feedback
in their fingers this also caused
another robot behind them this slave
robot to copy the motion simultaneously
by drawing on the volunteers backs
remove the touch feedback and delay the
slave robot by just 500 milliseconds and
the mismatch in brain signals induces
the feeling that there's someone behind
you obviously we're not going to get
robot arms packaged with our VR kits but
now that we're closer to understanding
just how the brain manages to get us all
worked up neat tricks like this could be
used to make games even more pant
browning ly scary that we ever thought
possible imagine playing amnesia and
some device alludes to a person being
behind you even though you're home alone
I don't even want to think about it so
that's a few of 2014's coolest
scientific advancements put to good use
in gaming definitely not what they're
intended for but it would be awesome
nonetheless any cool science you'd like
to see in video games let me know in the
comments box below or find me on Twitter
at Lucy James games can we'll be back
again next week thanks for watching
you